this is the real question here how do
you critique a movie that tried to be
camping in shitty how do you critique a
movie with no shame it's almost
impossible machete kills
so machete kills it's a sequel to
machete in which you have Danny Trejo as
machete who kills people with its right
machetes and you had your terrible yet
fun bloodbath exploitation movie that
you come to expect from a machete movie
now machete kills like machete is a
grindhouse film Dino death Proof and
planetary remember the grindhouse movies
a bummer is when you're watching this
movie it doesn't have the digital shitty
grain that the other grindhouse movies
had you know how they made it look like
sprockets were jumping and it had like
scratches and dust and it made it look
like a film print that's been around for
about three decades yeah machete kills
doesn't have any of that but rest
assured friends it's a grind house movie
in that it does its job really well the
movies not gonna win any prestigious
awards outside of Fangoria but I'm just
saying you don't have to be admired by
the Academy to have done your job well I
just saw the cast in this movie and I
was like that's awesome this movie has a
great legit cast Mel Gibson's in the
movie I have heard his answering machine
recording message and now he's in
machete kills and introducing Carlos
Estevez as the President of the United
States that's Charlie Sheen guys as a
marketing standpoint and just comedy
that's brilliant cuz not only is it his
name but it just goes to show you that
in Hollywood if you call a Jewish
producer by his actual Jewish name if
he's your boss you have to become
Mexican again that's a rule of the
hollywood that we didn't know and now we
do know and machete kills takes
everything to the next level in a really
cool kind of way I mean machete was a
total Mex ploy tation movie this is an
exploitation movie that's almost like a
shitty James Bond movie it has more spy
gadget rain starts dabbling into sci-fi
the first trailer you see at the
beginning of machete kills it's machete
kills again and I'm not gonna ruin it
for you but it's you watch it in your
life so this is where the franchise is
going yeah the movie is also a bit
sloppy I know when I just told you that
you're not supposed to take the movie
seriously in terms of construction you
still need a movie that does work and
I'm just saying as a cohesive line of
storytelling it doesn't always work
there's a lot of that happens in
machete kills it's almost like a Judd
Apatow
I walked out of machete kills going that
could have been a half an hour shorter
and it would have been great it would
have been perfect just like this happens
with machete and then he goes to here
then he goes to here then he goes to
here you feel like one or two of these
segways these plot lines could have been
taken out spliced together you would
have had a movie that's a half an hour
shorter and it's just fine Indiana
machete kills was made for people who
enjoyed the grindhouse movies who
enjoyed machete it's if you didn't enjoy
those movies you're not going to like
machete kills you're gonna hate it kind
of baffling to me that a lot of people
praised machete and machete kills it's
kind of getting on by critics that
simply tells me in the course of a
couple years between machete and machete
kills critics forgot how to have fun
with a movie like this it's a live
action cartoon or a live action graphic
novel that was made to just please that
really simple part of your brain just
like I want to seem exploitation blood
violence too many characters too many
plot lines but a lot of bloody fun with
machete I will say machete kills is a
great time
no alcohol required I'm waiting for
machete kills again I'm just saying so
your favorite can't be asked corny fun
bloody movie that's supposed to be can't
be asked corny fun bloody movie whatever
it is comment below let me know and just
so you guys know I'm actually going to
Las Vegas like at the time you're
watching this I will be in Las Vegas oh
hey if you're in Las Vegas tweet me but
I will review Tom Hanks going for the
Oscar when I get back on Monday until
then have a fun weekend catching up on
my other videos or going out and doing
normal people and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you